we have an epidemic in this population
and I might say needlessly people work
underneath no I don't think they should
in order to vent those Minds you have to
pump out the air within that mind which
is radioactive they didn't give it any
instruction nothing nothing
didn't tell us nothing
when was the mind abandoned close to
about 1960 or something like that but my
dad was still working up here but after
that I think it was close to 60 when he
used to work on all these mines around
here that's a fairly large mine this is
an underground mine yeah it's a probe
that it'll read anything but it mainly
reads alpha and beta particles and the
last dream was 340 counts a minute and
this up here and it's kind of wind
that's about that's about eight times
the background at one of the drilling
pipes the alpha beta cannon at 1,800
counts a minute at the air shaft the
Alpha Beta count was three hundred and
forty counts a minute what's the way
10800 so come back from there one's
enough I'd like to get at
[Music]
you couldn't pay me to go in here - for
its 1,100 counts a minute on the GM Pro
which reads mainly alphas and betas
we're coming out of the shaft mister
left a lot of [ __ ] you know these
ionizations are so energetic that you
can you can actually hear the
ionizations in the chamber without any
audio amplification at all it's 40 300
counts a minute that's on the probe that
reads practically no gam as it reads
mainly alphas and betas I just record
that for a second that that actually
you're talking about wouldn't do it down
by the ground was not so much wind
Sabbath tape so I'll just run out on
this
yeah the populace who live in close
proximity to those venting ducts from
uranium mines have concentrations that
are anywhere from ten to a hundred times
background level oh no angry smooth as I
was by his bedside when he died
I hold on to his hand when he died I
told him not to go I said daddy don't go
he did I feel like crying all the time I
just seen it's inside me they tell us
it's cancer that's what they said it
should Rock the government had a sole
monopoly and subsidized the uranium
industry in the United States it's a
lost generation that we still don't pay
any attention to in the United States
I know of no safe level first of all of
radiation in terms of either inducing a
cancer or a genetic effect I'm very
concerned about what radiation is doing
to the gene pool of mankind I was told
that there is more contamination in in
the world in the air and water from
military production weapons than there
is even from the private plans yes one
of the weapons facilities in in the
country and and is there a hazard to
health from the making of weapons
one major one is the Savannah River
plant in South Carolina this also is
quite a dirty plant life the Rocky Flats
plant it has five nuclear reactors five
nuclear plants of which three are still
operating the plant has they're a single
daily released Curie amounts of
petroleum in the air they release
millions of Curie's a tritium each year
contaminate the water as well as the air
the survey has been done around the
planet which shows over a thousand
square miles contaminated with plutonium
from the plant microgram quantities will
kill a beagle dog with certainty and we
feel like that similar amounts are even
small amounts of produced lung cancers
in humans most of nuclear weapons are
produced in South Carolina it's a waste
storage place of the United States one
of the natural sacrifice areas in water
is contaminated and its waters is going
right into our river systems and in time
million River which is a Savannah River
and really I think that people below us
that are pulling water supplies out of
Savannah River of picking up radiated
contamination and they're drinking this
water 99% of the semi-solid nuclear
waste in the United States is generated
by the military see the military has
about 140 nuclear power plants to run it
ships and submarines besides that there
is a tremendous amount of waste material
generated whenever you make nuclear
weapons most of your government
facilities are for nuclear bombs making
plutonium and manufacturing bombs for
this plutonium they shipped is plutonium
out the plutonium has been produced in
what are called production reactors at
the Savannah River plant
in South Carolina and at the Hanford
reservation in the state of Washington
in Hanford the highest dose recorded
with a man who been there for 25 years
or longer who had 50 rats is a total
cumulative dose but he got it in little
tiny little packages nobody ever had the
equivalent of a bomb survivor one big
hit
now all the recommendations say one big
hit is more dangerous than the little
one this is Bill King that's an
assumption and it is the basis of the
controlled nuclear waste if you dilute
it enough it will be safe well we say
diluted to add to the danger there was a
philosophy which was called the delusion
philosophy which means you if you dilute
something then it doesn't give any harm
but with all the knowledge we have today
we must say radiation is rien deucing
health damage regardless how little the
doses are so that even if you dilute
radiation much more you will having the
radioactive material being more widely
distributed and therefore the cancer
cases and all the health effects will
only be more widely distributed this is
the only effect of this delusion
photography it makes absolutely no
difference whether you have put it all
in one place or you have spread it out
because the total irradiation of human
beings the total number of beta
particles which are going to be smashing
into living tissue is the same in fact
if what some researchers like dr.
Stewart are saying is true it will be
even worse the amount of radiation which
came out of South Carolina is also huge
so you might imagine what the effect of
Savannah River plant simply due to the
operation has been to the public we
already know that radiation depresses
the ability of the body's immune defense
system to protect itself against a whole
variety of diseases and they put up
these signs saying danger hazardous
do not swim do not fish and it was like
it appeared one day and people said did
you know you can't go out the lower
three runs anymore and swim yeah yeah
the government's put up some kind of
signs out there and it never registered
with the local people that it really was
dangerous
what's the count it's about six thousand
counts a minute just under that no just
over sixty four hundred counts a minute
a lot higher than we were keep going
closer to the swamp and she looks like a
man-made drainage ditch what is it now
well still it went up a little hot yeah
it's up its up closer to 7,000 a minute
now hold it let's go on down by the spot
exactly seven thousand Council many of
you this feeds right out of the plant
yeah that's that leg up there goes right
up into the plant and feeds down to the
stance of the Savannah River will
forever change skills we just went off
scale look it's just a flick of the
switch but what is this mountain well
it's on the analogue it's reading about
10,000 counts a minute we're getting
exact really it's uh it's 10,000 counts
a minute go right down into the field
right into the water there where it's
real still it looks like about I'm
probably 11 or 12,000 counts a minute oh
no we'll get something exactly we're
doing 30-second reading so we can get we
can depend on them now if I put it right
down next to the water it's just over
12,000 about twelve thousand six hundred
well that's 15,000 counts let's go
the bad guy at ERISA what the background
here is about one thirtieth of that okay
let's go
that's the highest we pass hi this is
hot this is higher than we had standing
in front of the plant at West Valley in
New York come on it does it slower as we
move back after the road and back down
on this on the other scale again let's
revisit the roads you back down on the
scale already that's oh yeah yeah it's
just walking what it's what is it in
here that there are ten thousand and
twenty feet and you know what that means
when you get that kind of direct
drop-off as you move away it means it
really is a source I mean the source is
right there in that water and they just
ignore the fact that Allendale County
has the highest cancer death rate in the
state your father worked in the plant
before you he worked for 26 years out
there that was one of the main reasons
that I went to work out there because it
was you know he talked about it being
such a great place and a great job you
know and my father died last August
heart disease he had two pacemakers when
he died in June of 1961 they had a
release that was over a three-day period
it was a hundred and fifty times what
happened at Three Mile Island and
radioactive iodine I know these plants
aren't safe I know the Savannah River
plant isn't safe I know I know the
accidents that happened there I know
that my father worked on the plant I
know that my father personally got over
doses of radiation so great that they
would not let him come home to his
family and I can't sit back and be quiet
about it and not say anything about it
even now walking around how many people
have it on them right now just from
people they've known from the plant you
know how many people they sprinted to
walking around I know this topic they
stood up in does that protect them
against radiation
well they stood over the coveralls all
it does is protect them from
contamination you don't you know you've
got layers of cloth on so you don't get
the contamination on your skin the
radiation ionizing radiation still goes
right through them we were told that was
a reprocessing plant and everything was
safe they took care of all the harmful
things that could come along we thought
it was entirely safe when we work there
I had absorbed enough radiation than the
quota for a year in about tuning after
three minutes standing in this driveway
the ambient level we know that just
background level of gamma radiation is
about four to five times as high as it
is anywhere else in this region
you were reading out in the actual
number of counts was that just a count
that's account just 3185 we've had it on
for ten hours today all day long this
thing has never hasn't once read over
six hundred and fifty counts in the
thirty second period um now what is it
reading well the last one was three
thousand and seventy four for a thirty
second period the role of swish oh okay
sure let's go back to the road then I'm
sorry I thought it was public to the
parking lot